[Music]
[Music]
what technology can we really apply to
reducing global poverty and what I found
was quite surprising we started looking
at things like death rates in the 20th
century how they'd been improved and
very simple things turned out you'd
think maybe antibiotics made more
difference than clean water but it's
actually the opposite and so very simple
things off-the-shelf technologies that
we could find easily on the then early
web would clearly make a huge difference
to to that problem but I also in looking
at more powerful technologies and
nanotechnology and genetic engineering
and other new emerging kind of digital
technologies became very concerned about
the potential for abuse if you think
about it in history a long long time ago
we dealt with the problem of an
individual abusing another individual we
came with something the Ten Commandments
thou shalt not kill that's a kind of a
one on one thing we organized into
cities we had many people and to keep
the many from tyrannize in the one we
came up with concepts like individual
liberty and then did have to deal with
large groups say at the nation's state
level and we had to have mutual
non-aggression or through a series of
conflicts we eventually came to a rough
international bargain to largely keep
the peace
but now we have a new situation really
in a cement what people call an
asymmetric situation where technology is
so powerful that it extends beyond a
nation-state it's not the nation states
that have potential access to mass
destruction but the but individuals and
this is a consequence of the fact these
new technologies tend to be digital
we saw genome sequences you can download
the gene sequences of pathogens off
the Internet if you want to and clearly
someone recently I saw in a science
magazine they said well the 1918 flu is
too dangerous to FedEx around if people
want to use it in their labs for working
on research just reconstruct it yourself
so because we you know might get it
might break in FedEx so that this is
possible to do this is not deniable so
individuals in small groups super
empowered by access to these kind of
self-replicating technologies whether it
be biological or other are clearly a
danger in our world and the danger is
that they can cause roughly what's a
pandemic and we really don't have
experience with pandemics and we're also
not very good as a society at acting two
things we don't have direct and sort of
gut-level experience with so it's not
our nature it's not in our nature to
pre-act and in this case more more
piling on more technology doesn't solve
the problem because it only super
empowers people more so the solution has
to be as people like Russell and
Einstein and others imagine in a
conversation that existed in a much
stronger form I think early in the 20th
century that the solution had to be not
just a head but the heart you know
Paulo's public policy and moral progress
the civilizing the bargain that gives us
civilization is a bargain to not use
power we get our individual rights by
society protecting us from others using
not doing everything they can do but
largely doing only what is legal and so
to limit the danger of these new things
we have to limit ultimately ability of
individuals to have access essentially
to pandemic power and we also have to
have sensible defense because no no
limitation is going to prevent a crazy
person from doing something but you know
in the troubling thing is that it's much
easier to do something bad than to
defend against all possible bad thing so
the offensive uses really have any
symmetric advantage so these are the
kind of thoughts I was thinking in 1999
and 2000 and my friends told me I was
getting really depressed
and they were really worried about me
and then I signed a book contract to
write more gloomy thoughts about this
and moved into a hotel room in New York
with a with one room full of books on
the plague and you know nuclear bombs
exploding in New York where I would be
within the circle and so on and then I
was there on September 11th and I stood
in the streets with everyone and it was
quite it was quite an experience to be
there I got up the next morning and
walked out of the city and there were
all the Sanitation trucks were parked on
Houston Street ready to go down and
start taking the rubble away and I
walked down the middle up to the train
station and everything below 14th Street
was closed it was quite a compelling
experience but not really a I suppose a
surprise to someone who had this room
full of the books I it's always a
surprise that that it happened then and
there but it wasn't surprised that it
happened at all and everybody then
started writing about this thousands of
people started writing about this and I
eventually abandoned the book and I went
to and Chris called me to talk at the
conference I really don't talk about
this anymore because you know there's
enough frustrating and depressing things
going on but I agreed to come and say a
few things about this and I would say
that you know we can't give up the rule
of law to fight an asymmetric threat
which is what we seem to be doing
because of the present the people that
are in power because that's to give up
the thing that makes civilization and we
can't fight the threat in the kind of
stupid way we're doing because a
million-dollar act causes a billion
dollars of damage causes a trillion
dollar response which is largely
ineffective and arguably probably almost
certainly has made the problem worse so
we can't we can't fight the thing with a
million to one cost 1 to 1/2 a million
cost-benefit ratio so so after giving up
on the book and I had the great honor to
be able to join Kleiner Perkins about a
year ago and to work through venture
capital when the innovator side and to
try to find some innovations that could
address what I saw as some of these big
problems things where
you know a factor of 10 difference can
make a factor of a thousand difference
in the outcome I've been amazed in the
last year at the incredible quality of
an excitement of the innovations that
have come across my desk it's
overwhelming at times I'm very thankful
for Google and Wikipedia so I can
understand at least a little of what
people are talking about who come
through the doors but I wanted to share
with you three areas that I'm
particularly excited about and that
relate to the problems that I was
talking about in the wired article the
first is this whole area of education
and it really relates to a Nicholas was
talking about with a hundred dollar
computer and that is to say that there's
a lot of legs left in Moore's law the
most advanced transistors today are at
65 nanometers and we've seen and I've
had the pleasure to invest in companies
that give me great confidence that will
extend Moore's law all the way down to
roughly the 10 nano 10 nanometer scale
another factor of say six and
dimensional reduction which should give
us about another factor of a hundred in
raw improvement in what the chips can do
and so to put that in practical terms if
something costs about a thousand dollars
today say the best personal computer you
can buy that might be its cost I think
we can have that in 2020 for ten dollars
okay now just imagine what that $100
computer will be in 2020 as a tool for
education I think the challenge for us
is I'm very certain that that will
happen the challenges will we develop
the kind of educational tools and thinks
with a net to make it to let us take
advantage of that device I'd argue today
that we have incredibly powerful
computers but we don't have very good
software for them and it's only in
retrospect after the better software
comes along you take it and you run it
on a ten-year-old machine and say God
the machine was that fast
remember when they took the Apple Mac
interface and they put it back on the
Apple - the Apple - was perfectly
capable of running that kind of
interface we just didn't know how to do
at the time so given that we we know and
should believe because Moore's law has
been like the constant I mean it's just
been it's been very predictable progress
over the last 40 years or whatever we
can we can know what the computers are
going to be like in 2020 it's great that
we have initiatives to say go scope
create the education and educate people
in the world cuz that's a great force
for peace and we can give everyone in
the world a $100 computer a $10 computer
in the next 15 years the second area
that I'm focusing on is the
environmental problem because that's
clearly going to put a lot of pressure
on this world we'll hear a lot more
about that from Al Gore very shortly
the thing that we see is the kind of
Moore's Law trend that's driving
improvement and our ability to address
the environmental problem is is new
materials we have a challenge because
the urban population is growing in this
century from 2 billion to 6 billion in a
very short amount of time people are
moving to the cities they all need clean
water the energy they need
transportation and we want them to
develop in a green way we're reasonably
efficient in the industrial sectors
we've made improvements in energy and
resource efficiency but the consumer
sector especially in America is very
very inefficient but these new materials
bring such incredible innovations that
there's a strong basis for hope that
these things will be so profitable that
they can be brought to the market now I
want to give you a specific example of a
new material that was discovered 15
years ago if we take carbon nanotubes
you know jima discovered them in 1991
they just have incredible properties and
these are the kinds of things we're
going to discover as we start to
engineer at the nano scale their
strengths they're almost the strongest
material of tensile strength material
known there's they're very very stiff
they stretch very very little in two
dimensions if you make a like a fabric
out of them they're 30 times stronger
than Kevlar and if you make a
three-dimensional structure like a
buckyball that they have all sorts of
incredible
properties say if you shoot a particle
at them and knock a hole in them they
repair themselves they goes it and they
repair the hole in femtoseconds which is
not it's really quick if you if you
shine light on them they produce
electricity effective you flash them
with a camera they catch on fire if you
put electricity on them they admit light
if you run current through them you can
run a thousand times more current
through one of these than through a
piece of metal you can make both P and
n-type semiconductors which means you
can make transistors out of them they
conduct heat along their length but not
across the well there's no width but not
in the other direction if you stack them
up that's uh property of carbon fiber
also if you put particles in them and
they they go shooting out the tip
they're like little miniature all linear
accelerators or electron guns the inside
of the nanotubes is so small the
smallest one 0.7 nanometers dead it's
basically a quantum world it's a strange
place inside of nanotubes and so we
begin to see and we've seen business
plans already were the kind of things
Lisa Randall is talking about her in
there I had one business plan where I
was trying to learn more about Witten's
cosmic dimension strings to try to
understand what the phenomena was going
on in this proposed nano material so at
in the inside of a nanotube we're really
at the at the limit here so what we see
is with these and other new materials
that we can we can do things with
different properties lighter stronger
and apply these new materials to the
environmental problems new materials
that can make water new materials that
can make fuel cells work better new
materials that catalyze chemical
reactions that that cut pollution and so
on ethanol new ways of making ethanol
new ways of making electric
transportation the whole green the whole
green dream because it can be profitable
and we've dedicated we just raised a new
fund we dedicated a hundred million
dollars to these kinds of investments we
believe the Genentech the compact the
Lotus Tucson the Netscape the Amazon the
Google in this Indies field are yet to
be found because this materials
revolution
we'll drive these things forward the
third area that we're working on and we
just announced last week we were all in
New York we raised two hundred million
dollars a specialty fund to work on a
pandemic and bio defense and to give you
an idea the last fund that kleiner
raised was a four hundred million dollar
fund so this is for us as a very
substantial fund and what we did is over
the last few months well a few months
ago Ray Kurzweil and I wrote an op-ed in
New York Times about how publishing the
1918 genome was very dangerous and John
Doerr and Brooke and others got got
concerned for bars and we started
looking around at what the world was
doing about being prepared for a
pandemic and we saw a lot of gaps and so
we asked ourselves you know can we find
innovative things that will go fill
these gaps and as Brooke told me on a
break here he's found so much stuff he
can't sleep just there's so many great
technologies out there we're essentially
buried and we need them you know we have
one antiviral that people are talking
about stockpiling that still works
roughly that's Tamiflu fátima flu the
the virus is resistant it was resistant
to Tamiflu we've discovered with AIDS we
need cocktails to to work well so that
the viral resistance we need several
antivirals we need better surveillance
we need networks that can find out
what's going on we need rapid
Diagnostics so we can tell if somebody
has a strain of a strain of flu each
meal I've only identified very recently
we got to be able to make the rapid
Diagnostics quickly we need new
antivirals and cocktails we need new
kinds of vaccines vaccines that are
broad-spectrum vaccines that we can
manufacture quickly cocktails more
polyvalent vaccines we'd normally get a
trivalent vaccine against three possible
strains we need we need we don't know
where this thing is going we believe
that if we could fill these 10 gaps we
have a chance to help really reduce the
risk of a pandemic and the difference
between a normal flu season and a
pandemic is about a factor of a thousand
in
in deaths and certainly enormous
economic impact so we're very excited
because we think we can fund 10 or
speedup 10 projects and see them come to
mark in the next couple years that will
address this so if we can address use
technology help address education help
address the environment health address
the pandemic does that solve the larger
problem that I was talking about in the
word article and I'm afraid the answer
is really no because you can't solve a
problem with the management technology
with more technology if we let an
unlimited amount of power loose then we
will a very small number of people will
be able to abuse it we can't fight it I
get it in a million-to-one disadvantage
so what we need to do is we need better
policy and for example some things we
could do that would be policy solutions
which are not really in the political
air right now but perhaps with a change
of administration would be use markets
markets are a very strong force for
example rather than trying to regulate
away problems which probably won't work
if we could price into the cost of doing
business the cost of catastrophe so that
people who are doing things that had a
higher cost of catastrophe would have to
take insurance against that risk so if
you want to put a drug on the market you
could put it on but it wouldn't have to
be approved by regulators you'd have to
convince an actuary that it would be
safe and if you apply the notion of
insurance more more broadly you can you
can use a more powerful force a market
force to provide feedback how could you
keep the law I think the law would be a
really good thing to keep well you have
to hold people accountable
the law requires accountability today
scientists technology and technologists
businessmen engineers don't take any
don't have any personal responsibility
for the consequences of their actions so
if you tie that you have to tie that
back with the law and finally I think we
have to do something that's not really
it's almost unacceptable to say is which
we have to begin to design the future we
can't pick the future but we can steer
the future our investment in trying to
prevent pandemic flu is affecting the
distribution of possible outcomes we may
not be able to stop it
but the likelihood that it will
past this is lower if we focus on that
problem so we can we can design the
future if we choose what kind of things
we'd want to have happen and not have
happen and steer the steer us to a lower
risk place like Vice President Gore will
talk about how we could steer the
climate trajectory into a lower
probability of catastrophic risk but
above all what we have to do is we have
to help the good guys the people on the
defensive side have an advantage over
the people who want to abuse things and
we have to do to do that as we have to
limit access to certain information and
growing up as we have and holding very
high the value of free speech this is a
hard thing for us to accept for all of
us to accept it's especially hard for
the scientists to accept who still
remember you know Galileo essentially
locked up and who are still fighting
this battle against the church but
that's the price of having a
civilization for the price of retaining
the rule of law is to limit the access
to the great and kind of unbridled power
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
at Rolex the pursuit of excellence is a
passion the challenge to produce a watch
movement precise enough and reliable
enough to be called a Rolex movement
[Music]
after years of research and design
involving dozens of engineers scientists
and watchmakers the result was
revolutionary
the Rolex blue para chrome hair spring
created from a unique paramagnetic alloy
it's unaffected by magnetic fields and
up to ten times more resistant to shocks
than a standard hair spring the blue
para chrome hair spring an exclusive
Rolex technology 100% conceived patented
and produced by Rolex
[Music]
you
[Music]